hello my name is reto meier and welcome
to this week in Android development on
Monday September 16 2013 last week the
Android design and action team focused
their laser-like attention on the UX
issues we encounter most often and i was
back for the next chapter of my dev bite
series on efficient data transfers this
time looking at ways to batch and bundle
your transfers using sync adapters our
favorite intern was back to teach us
about ListView cell insertion animations
and for mobile developers of a slightly
different stripe Todd Kerpelman offered
an introduction to using Google Play
game services on iOS this week joined
wolf and Joanna as they talk you through
the development of NFC hunt as featured
this year at Google i/o and I'll be back
again for another efficient data
transfers dev bite this time looking at
how to eliminate polling and refresh
buttons with Google Cloud messaging we
have also got another animation dev by
looking at how to implement a folding
layout and few designers based in New
York City join nick and roman at the New
York Android developers made up on the
20th in other in person action this
year's season of death vests has
officially kicked off so check the site
for details of google developer group
led by fests near you that's all for
this week in Android development be sure
to check out this week's bytes I'm
rottenmeier and I thought I found the
connector it's just a reflector